NEIL: ALL RIGHT, DONALD TRUMP IS
NOT ASKING ANY MORE.
HE’S NOT BEING NICE ANY MORE
TELLING GENERAL MOTORS, I ASKED
YOU TO START RAMPING UP AND
MAKING MORE VENTILATORS.
YOU’VE BEEN DRAGGING YOUR FEET
SO NOW I AM DEMANDING YOU TO DO
SO.
USING SOME DEFENSE POWERS THAT
THE CHIEF EXECUTIVE OF AMERICA
HAS, TO TAKE BACK TO THE KOREAN
WAR TO MAKE THAT HAPPEN BUT WILL
IT HAPPEN?
AND IS IT A LITTLE TOO LITTLE
TOO LATE?
IT’S NEVER TOO LATE FOR MARK
CUBAN BUT IT’S A GOOD MOVE ON
THE PART OF THE PRESIDENT HE
SAYS, HE JOINS US RIGHT NOW I’M
TALKING ABOUT THE DALLAS
MAVERICKS OWNER AND OF COURSE
MULTIBILLION AIR MARK CUBAN.
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE PRESIDENT
IS DOING HERE FORCING CORPORATE
AMERICA’S HAND TO HELP OUT AS
MUCH AS PRESIDENT ROOSEVELT
DID AFTER THE ATTACK ON PEARL
HARBOR TO REV UP OUR MILITARY
MACHINE?
>> AS LONG AS HE GETS THE JOB
DONE THAT’S ALL THAT MATTERS,
THERE’S OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE’S LIVES
ON THE LINE SO SOMETHING HAS TO
HAPPEN.
THEY WERE TALKING BEFORE I DON’T
KNOW WHAT WENT WRONG BUT IF IT
GETS GENERAL MOTORS TO GET THE
JOB DONE I’M ALL FOR IT.
NEIL: YOU WERE CRITICAL OF 3M.
NOT SO MUCH THEIR RAMPING UP
PRODUCTION OF VENTILATORS AND
OTHER THINGS, BUT MORE TO THE
POINT THAT THEY WEREN’T DOING
ENOUGH ON THE FACE MASK SIDE TO
KEEP THOSE PRICES DOWN.
MAYBE I’M GETTING THAT WRONG.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN?
>> SURE.
3M FIRST THEY GET CREDIT FOR
RAMPING UP PRODUCTION
ABSOLUTELY, BUT THEY SELL UP
UNTIL RECENTLY THEY SELL AS BEST
I CAN TELL EXCLUSIVELY THROUGH
DISTRIBUTION, MEANING IF YOU GO
TO MARIAH CAREY WEBSITE THERE’S
A LIST OF DISTRIBUTORS THAT
RESELL THEIR N 95 MASKS.
NOW, WHAT’S BEEN HAPPENING IS
OBVIOUSLY, EVERYBODY IS AWARE OF
THE SHORTAGES AND THE CRISIS
AROUND THE N 95 MASK NOT BEING
AVAILABLE FOR HEALTH CARE
WORKERS, AND THEY APPARENTLY
HAVE JUST LET THEIR DISTRIBUTORS
PRICE WHATEVER THEY WANT TO
PRICE THE MASK AT, AND A LOT OF
CASES, THEY’RE NOT SELLING THEM
TO HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS, THOSE
DISTRIBUTORS ARE SELLING
THEM TO RESELLERS AND BLACK
MARKETERS WHO ARE THEN TRYING TO
JACK UP THE PRICE EVEN HIGHER
THAN THE DISTRIBUTORS DID AND MY
POINT WAS IN ALL OF THIS ,
THERE’S A CONTRACTUAL
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN THE 3M
LICENSE DISTRITORS AND
3M CORPORATE.
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN VERY EASY FOR
THEM TO SAY VERY STRONGLY
THAT IF YOU DON’T SELL, IF YOU
DON’T TAKE THE INVENTORY WE’RE
PROVIDING YOU AND SELL DIRECTLY
TO HOSPITALS AND HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS THAT NEED THE MASKS,
WHEN YOUR CONTRACT COMES UP
WE’RE GOING TO END THAT CONTRACT
BUT THAT’S NOT WHAT THEY DID AND
I HAVE A HUGE PROBLEM WITH THAT
AND WHAT’S HAPPENING NOW IS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND I’VE
TRIED TO HELP AS MUCH AS I CAN
TURNING OVER SOME OF THESE
PEOPLE WHO SAY THEY HAVE
INVENTORY AND WANT TO SELL IT TO
ME AT JACKED UP PRICE, THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
STARTING TO GO AFTER SOME OF THE
MIDDLEMEN WHO HAVE GOTTEN IN
THE WAY AND HELPED MAKE THIS
MARKET REALLY IN EFFICIENT
AND ENABLE ALL OF THE PRICE
GOUGING AND MY FEELING HAS BEEN
IF THE CEO OF 3M SAYS DON’T DO
IT, THIS COULD HAVE STOPPED A
LONG TIME AGO IF THE CEO OF 3M
SAID I ONLY WANT YOU TO SELL
TO HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS THIS
WOULD HAVE STOPPED A LONG
TIME AGO.
NEIL: MARK, WHILE I HAVE YOU,
THE PRESIDENT YESTERDAY WHEN HE
ADDRESSED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
ONE OF HIS DAILY BRIEFINGS HE
AND HIS TASK FORCE HAVE HAD SAID
HE TOLD HIS VICE PRESIDENT NOT
TO CALL GOVERNORS WHO ARE NOT
APPRECIATIVE OF HIS CORONAVIRUS
HELP.
THAT WOULD INCLUDE THE GOVERNORS
OF WASHINGTON STATE, AND
MICHIGAN WITH WHOM HE HAD A
RELATIONSHIP I GUESS AND THEY
WITH HE AND NOW IT DIDN’T STOP
FROM HIM DECLARING THE DISASTER
ASSISTANCE THAT MICHIGAN WANTED
BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK TO CORNER
OR  CITE THOSE WHO ARE
APPRECIATIVE OF HIS EFFORTS
VERSUS THOSE WHO ARE NOT?
>> I MEAN IT’S WRONG, OBVIOUSLY
BUT THE GOOD NEWS IS I THINK AND
YOU HATE TO SAY THIS.
I THINK THERE’S A LOT OF PEOPLE
IN GOVERNMENT WHO ARE JUST
IGNORING WHAT HE SAYS ON TWITTER
AND IGNORING WHAT HE SAYS IN THE
BRIEFING AND DOING THE RIGHT
THING.
I MEAN, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WHO
HE IS.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO CHANGE HIM
AND I THINK AFTER THREE YEARS
NOW, PEOPLE UNDERNEATH HIM IN
GOVERNMENT AND DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS KNOW THAT IF THEY
JUST GO ABOUT THEIR JOB AND DO
THE RIGHT THING IT’LL ALL WORK
OUT, SO WHILE IT’S OBVIOUSLY NOT
THE SMARTEST THING TO DO BY THE
PRESIDENT, THE GOOD NEWS IS
AT LEAST WITH PEOPLE THAT I’VE
DEALT WITH, EVEN AT LOWEST LEVEL
S THEY ARE LIKE JUST HEAD
DOWN, DOING THE RIGHT THING
DOING THEIR JOBS KNOWING THAT
HELPS TO GET THE VENTILATORS
HELPING TO GET MASKS WHERE THEY
NEED TO BE IS THE RIGHT THING TO
DO.
NEIL: SO IF HIS WORDS ARE NOT
MATCHING HIS ACTIONS IN A GOOD
WAY, YOU MIGHT BE TALKING AND
ANGRY AT THOSE GOVERNORS WHO ARE
NOT APPRECIATIVE OF HIS EFFORTS
BUT HE’S NOT TAKING IT OUT ON
THEM IN TERMS AT LEAST IN THE
CASE OF MICHIGAN ON AID OR
DISASTER RELIEF THAT THE
MICHIGAN GOVERNOR WANTED AND
SHE GOT.
>> YEAH, BUT STILL, WHY SAY IT
IN THE FIRST PLACE?
LEADERS LEADER AND I’LL GIVE
DONALD TRUMP CREDIT FOR THINGS
WHEN HE DOES THE RIGHT THING.
HE’S DEFERRED TO DR. FAUCI, HE’S
REFERRED TO HIS EXPERTS WHEN IT
COMES TO CORONAVIRUS AS OF
RECENTLY, BUT COME ON.
IN A CRISIS LIKE THIS , THIS IS
NOT THE TIME TO CREATE ANIMOSITY
AND INCREASE THE PEOPLE’S
THREATS, AND I RECOGNIZE HE’S
STILL BEHIND THE SCENES, HE’S
ALLOWING THINGS TO HAPPEN, HE
WOULD HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
STOP THEM IF HE WANTED TO, BUT
YEAH, LOOK AND LET ME ADD TO IT,
IN THIS TIME OF IMPERFECT
INFORMATION, NO MATTER WHAT ANY
LEADERS DO IT’S GOING TO BE
WRONG AT SOME LEVEL, BUT THERE’S
NO REASON TO ADD TO THE STRESS
AND IT’S UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE IT
TAKES AWAY FROM THE GOOD THINGS
HE IS DOING, LIKE WHAT HE’S DONE
WITH GENERAL MOTORS, LIKE
GETTING EQUIPMENT, LIKEN ABLING
FEMA.
THERE’S SO MANY THINGS THAT HAVE
HAPPENED IN THIS CRISIS THAT
HAVE TURNED OUT TO BE POSITIVE
THAT HIS ADMINISTRATION HAS
ENABLED BUT HE DIMINISHES ALL OF
THAT WITH THE ANCILLARY
COMMENTARY AND I DON’T THINK
HE’S EVER GOING TO CHANGE SO IT
IS WHAT IT IS BUT IT’S
UNFORTUNATE.
NEIL: WHILE I STILL HAVE YOU,
MARK, A LOT OF PEOPLE WANT TO
SEE AN END GAME TO THIS , THE
PRESIDENT WAS TALKING ABOUT
MAYBE SORT OF EASING UP ON A LOT
OF RESTRICTIONS, AND SHELTERING
AT HOME AND STUFF, AS SOON AS
EASTER.
HE’S BACKED AWAY FROM THAT,
OTHERS SAID THEY SIMPLY DON’T
KNOW WHAT IS A GOOD TIME TO
START THINKING THAT WAY.
HAVE YOU GIVEN THAT MUCH THOUGHT
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> YEAH, MY THOUGHT IS I HAVE
ONE THOUGHT.
I’M NOT DOING ANYTHING WITH MY
EMPLOYEES UNTIL I KNOW THEY ARE
ABSOLUTELY SAFE.
I’M NOT GOING TO ASK THEM TO
COME TO WORK.
LEAVE THEIR HOUSE.
ALL OF THIS IS UNCERTAIN, NOBODY
HAS ANSWERS AND WE’RE MAKING
PROGRESS, THAT’S THE GOOD NEWS.
YOU’RE SEEING FROM ABBOT LABS
THE 15 TO 45 MINUTE TEST SO THAT
WE CAN QUICKLY DETERMINE IF THEY
HAVE COVID-19.
THAT’S A GREAT STEP FORWARD SO I
TRUST SCIENCE.
I TRUST AMERICAN INGENUITY I
TRUST OUR ABILITY TO CREATE NEW
SOLUTIONS AND THERAPIES, AND
WHEN THOSE EXPERTS, WHEN DR.
FAUCI TELLS ME IT’S OKAY TO
LET MY EMPLOYEES LEAVE THE HOUSE
, THAT’S WHEN I’LL DO
IT.
FOR ALL THE REASONS WE JUST
MENTIONED EARLIER, ALL THE CHIT
CHAT THAT’S GOING ON, ALL THE
DISCUSSIONS AND THE PRESS
BRIEFING, YOU KNOW, THAT’S
REALLY NOT RELEVANT TO THE
DECISION-MAKING PROCESS.
NEIL: MARK CUBAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MY BEST TO YOU AND YOUR FAMILY